hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game that was played in round
one of the video World Blitz
championship last year uh you guys
requested it quite a lot as Magnus when
he actually arrived to the game he only
had 30 seconds on the clock I think he
made his first move with 29 seconds on
the clock uh and the game starts with
both players having three minutes now as
I understand it uh Magnus was a skiing
in the day before the day uh prior uh to
this game being played Magnus won the
world rapid championship and now there
are two days of Blitz and Magnus wins
King in the morning uh he was laid due
to an accident I don't think it was his
accident or rather the accident of the
car that he was in I think it was a
general accident that happened somewhere
on the road that's why they uh he was
late for the first game but he arrived
and here there's even
um a nice photo of this let me just
check it out where I have it yeah there
it is uh here you have it uh there you
can see Magnus man taking his first move
and he only has uh 31 seconds of the
clock which means that he made it with
29 seconds and he got the two seconds
increment and you can see that um
uh kovalev's uh clock is almost at the
full three minute uh so that being said
let's check it out and let's see what
Magnus can do with 30 seconds on the
clock meaning pretty much that he will
have to play the entire game on
increment make the move again two
seconds make a move again two seconds
otherwise he's gonna run out of time
very very quickly so kovalev uh with E4
Magnus replies with E6 he goes for the
French defense D4 D5 and now kovalev
plays uh e captress on D5 which is not
the way to seek Advantage with white
playing against the French but it is
maybe a way to get a nice clean draw
against Magnus especially since he's
been late for the game he only has 30
seconds on the clock uh making him a
fight for a win here with black in a
position that's pretty much uh a
well-known uh draw is is definitely the
way to go but okay he captures on the
five wave Knight F3 Bishop to D6 and now
uh Pawn to C4 we have Knight to F6
Knight to C3 and here at Magnus castles
and here kovalev really started spending
time on the clock calculating whether
it's okay or not to capture the pawn on
D5 and at the moment that he captures it
he was already down to one minute and 21
seconds and the clock and Magnus was
still up to some 35 seconds now some
people were saying that kovalev was
being fair and he was letting his own
time run out sort of to equalize his
time with magnuses uh but uh I have no
way of confirming if this is actually
true or was he just studying the
position position very deeply uh so here
uh he plays C captures on D5 like I said
but a probably best way is to play C5 If
he if he wants to keep the tension uh if
he wants to gain as much as possible
from the game let's say rookie eight
check freeing of the f8 square for the
bishop Bishop to f8 and now let's say
castles and Bishop death
um uh five uh stopping Rook to B1 uh
White will play the usual a3b4 and it's
a pretty nice position for both both but
in the game c characters and D5 was
played he wins the pawn temporarily and
Magnus will of course go after the pawn
with the Knight so here Rook d8 check
Bishop to E2 and not Knight B to D7
and here uh what's amazing about this
position is that even though Magnus uh
started the game with only 30 seconds on
the clock here he plays Knight B to D7
he gains his two seconds uh increment
and then he doesn't hit the clock he
first a perfectly aligns all of the
pieces
to the center of their squares and only
then does he hit the clock so obviously
it's something that mere means a lot to
him so here we have Castles by kovalev
and now H6 here uh the position has been
reached before known moves or something
like Bishop C for Bishop to B5 Knight to
B5 is in one move but here we have Rook
to E1 and it is now as of move 10 that
we have a completely new game uh just a
second I have to let Meadow in in the
room
foreign
there we go uh all right so Rook do you
want completely new game and now we have
Knight to B6 Magnus now goes after the
D5 pawn and now Knight the E5 and this
uh uh marks the moment where kovalev
also falls below the one minute Mark we
have Knight B captures and D5 Bishop to
F3 now putting pressure on the Knight
and the just C6 by Magnus with Queen to
B3 with Queen to B3 color and now drops
down to 22 seconds on the clock Magnus
uh still some uh 28 seconds on the clock
uh we have Queen to B6 Magnus now wants
to go into the end game Knight captures
on D5 Knight captures on D5 Bishop
captures and d5c captures on D5 and now
kovalev trades captures captures the
Queens get traded off the board and
Bishop to D2 and now we have this
position where a Magnus has a double B
Pawn but this also means that he has a
semi-open uh a file for his Rook so F6
chasing away the Knight Knight to D3 and
now Rook captures an E1 we have Bishop
captures anyone uh qualif captured this
um with two seconds on the clock uh and
now he's uh playing the rest of the game
on increment as well Rook the A4 by
Magnus going after the D4 pawn and now
Bishop to C3 Bishop to F5 putting
pressure on the Knight and not Knight
the E1 and here King the F7 uh also B5
B4 is a very nice idea we have a three
now uh and Magnus plays B5 we have Rook
to C1 and now Rook the C4 by Magnus uh
and here kovalev plays Rook to D1 both
of them playing pretty much instantly
and here uh Magnus has a completely
winning move he he can play Bishop
captures on A3 uh which will I mean if B
captures an A3 then you pick up the
bishop and C3 you attack the A3 Pawn if
white defense that you go after the C4
Pawn uh this will be completely winning
for Magnus but here as they were so low
on time I believe magnus's brain was in
in just in a complete strategy mode so
he was not looking for tactics even if
you know the this tactic was screaming
Magnus would not see it as he was trying
to position everything perfectly for a
nice strategical uh and maybe a winning
scenario so here he plays Pawn to B4 a
characters Bishop captures and now
Bishop captures Rook captures he goes
now uh into a rook and Bishop versus
rook and Knight end game Rook the D2
defending and now Pawn to G5 we have F3
upon the H5 King F2 and now Pawn to H
for both players some
still very much playing gun increment G3
we have H captors and g3h captress and
King the E6 now we have Knight the G2
King to D6 and now Knight the E3 going
after the bishop so Bishop to E6 King to
E2 and now Rook the B3 we have King the
F2 and now Rook the B4 uh King to E2
kovalev offers a draw with with the
repetition here and Magnus declines Rook
to A4 we have King to F2 Bishop to D7
and now Pawn to G4 we have rooked the A1
and now Rook the D1 offering a trait of
Rooks Magnus declines and Rogue back to
D2 and only now Magnus starts advancing
the B Pawn Pawn to B5 King to E2 Now
Pawn to B4 we have King to D3 trying to
get the king all the way uh to to harass
the rook and now Bishop the B5 check
King to C2 and Bishop to C4 nicely
controlling all of the squares here King
to B1 and now Rook all the way back back
to A8 you have to move the Rook there's
the thread of Knight captures and C4
just removing the defender of The Rook
so Rook to A8 we have King to C2 and now
Rook the E8 putting pressure on the
Knight Knight captures on C4 here yeah
coal level succumbs the time pressure uh
you have to keep everything on the board
Knight F5 check for example King C6 and
now you play anything and you you keep
the tension but after Knight captures in
C4 this allows Magnus to gain the
advantage here now he gets the two pawns
here and at some point it will be
possible to create a pass Pawn so here
Pawn to D5 we have Rook the E3 by Magnus
uh we have rooked the D4 now going after
the pawn here just onto B3 with check
King to D2 and now Rook captures an F3
Rook captures and C4 and now King
captures on D5 now Magnus is up a pawn
Rook to B4 and now King to C5 getting
the Rook
uh out of uh either attacking the uh the
B3 Pawn or even defending the G4 Pawn so
Rook to A4 and now Rook the F4 offering
a trade of Rooks of course if you trade
here uh the the end game is completely
winning for black it seems like you can
reach the F4 Pawn uh but not really King
F3 King the E5 you defend and now there
is nothing you have to move King back
King T4 King F2 now F3 and there are no
moves you cannot pull the pawn and you
have to move the king so after Rook to
F4 we have rooked the A6 and now we have
King to D4 uh Rook to D6 with check King
the E5 Rook to B6 and only now Rook
captures on G4 we have Rook capture some
B3 and Rook the G2 check now Magnus with
two connected past pawns is in a
completely winning position of course
King E1 G4 we have rooked the B8 and
Here pawn to F5 we have Pawn to B4 and
Magnus just puts the Rook behind the
pass Pawn we have Rook to B2 and he was
in this position and move 59 that
vladislav kovalev resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
Magnus wins the first Blitz game after
uh after winning the uh the uh World
rapid Championship which is uh which is
quite nice as he only had 29 seconds
when he actually started the game now if
you're interested how to win this it's
fairly easy you just push those pawns
let's say B5 G3 you're gonna play King
to a font to stop G2 check still G2
check King G1 F4 and now once the pawn
reaches F3 the G2 Pawn will be defended
and Rook to B1 check will be deadly
that's pretty much it if B6 spawn to F3
um sorry about that if B6 Pawn to F3 and
now you have to start checking Rook d8
check but it is very easy to avoid those
checks Rook to f8 checking the E3 are
gonna give a check here King tadi to
another check here King te1 and after
Rook to E8 check you will block with the
rook and now that's it after check will
win the game or you trade here captures
captures or even a better King captures
now uh you will have F2 with check and
after B7 F2 with check King captures on
G2 F1 Queen let's say King to G3 now
you're gonna play Queen F3 check King to
H2 and you can choose either you capture
the pawn or you prepare Checkmate either
is fine you can even allow white to
bring a Queen into the game and now you
Checkmate the white king so that's uh
one uh one way to do it but of course
kovalev knows this and there is no point
in continuing the game uh but yeah some
a lot of people were saying that kovalev
uh purposefully allowed his time to run
out sort of the equalizes time with
Magnus I I don't know if this is true I
have no way of confirming this and it
doesn't seem like uh something anyone
should do but then again it is
definitely
uh possible and I don't know I if if
Magnus was on time and this was the
position on the board I I seriously
doubted that uh kovalev would go for E
Captain D5 even though okay it's the
exchange variation of the French uh I've
seen it uh being played uh in in Blitz
on on on a top level uh but I don't know
maybe not the the greatest attempt at
going for Advantage
um uh with white against Magnus uh but
okay it's Blitz uh who knows why anyone
does anyone uh Magnus uh showed that he
can uh pretty much play an increment for
the entire game and what that one moment
you give him you know a chance of
Advantage uh he will take it even though
he missed that uh here after Rook to D1
he missed this bishop captures an A3
idea but like I said I think that was
just because his mind was so focused on
going for strategical ideas that he
wasn't even considering such uh such
things
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it a lot of you suggested
it as it uh is uh I mean uh just uh just
very nice how how with 30 seconds you
can beat someone with three minutes so
it's not the first time Magnus did it I
I think uh you know he did it many many
times maybe this is the first time he
did it against uh a grand master of
kovalev's level uh but uh yeah that's
what it is to play Magnus uh so yeah uh
that's it hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to uh ping pong master Max uh obviously
if if that is your nickname you are a
true master of ping pong and I would
like to thank Ben Benjamin uh Yoon young
and rabbit 7 for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens uh in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and if you want to watch the
original footage of this matchup uh
first link in the description below will
be a video on just basing this channel
do check it out see you soon